jetzt gehen sie ein stück zurück kommen
sie nicht mehr
huf terror auf der straße und die
angehörigen heulend rennen raus sagen
jetzt haben sie doch bitte etwas geduld
ist krasseste beispiel ist haye puppe
nach meinem unternehmen hier ist auf
meinen dazu wie los gegangen ich bin
letztlich unter nachdem ins gesicht
geschlagen
dort haben sie denn in solchen
situationen probleme da kann ich merke
nur dass es ans herz der alltag dieser
helfer kümmerer und retter der ist auch
ohne anfeindungen schon hart genug wenn
hier der alarm geht ist dafür status 3
am funk kunden auf ihr ausdrücken ist
eine minute 30 und wenn es ernst
[Musik]
ja ich stehe auf der drehleiter der
feuerwehr
das ist schon was ganz besonderes aber
wir sind in der tat nicht zum spaß hier
sondern zu einem ernsten thema angriff
auf die helfer immer mehr polizisten
sanitäterinnen und sanitäter und
feuerwehrleute werden zu opfern und in
ihrer arbeit belästigt und bedroht das
finden wir geht gar nicht und darüber
wollen wir sprechen
der alltag der feuerwehrleute ist schon
hart genug und das durfte ich am eigenen
leib erleben
früh am morgen dienst übergabe in der
fahrzeughalle die neue 24 stunden
schicht beginnt die einsatz schiffe sind
bereit die hose darüber gerollt das
heißt wir schrumpfen einfach nur noch
die reihen sie haben normalerweise eine
minute richtig als wenn jeder erlangen
geht bis dafür status 3 am funk drücken
dafür aus rücken ist eine minute 30 und
ganz ernst da die lästigen albrecht
bringt mich zum drehleiter steigen
sie machen das super an das schon mal
gemacht
23 meter hoch
das entspricht dem achten stock eines
gebäudes man mag man gar nicht
anstrengend ist aber es ist anstrengend
atemschutz im bogen 18 kilo auf dem
rücken maske helm und ab und die strecke
normalerweise ohne licht für die kamera
heute in hellen flammen
den beiden formaten wir kämpfen uns
durch das gitter gewählt am ende
personenrettung die dummies sind
realistisch wäre das ist ja ein krasser
druck und eine psychische belastung wie
gehen sie damit um
also in dem moment denke ich überhaupt
gar nichts nach außer das was ich auch
dass ich trainiert wurde
das ist eine entscheidung die geht fast
ins im team egal ob lösch oder
rettungseinsatz anwendungen gehören
inzwischen zum feuerwehr alter sowie
lästige gaffer und handy filme
jetzt haben sie denn in solchen
situationen tatsächlich gekippt ist man
fühlt sich über immer und überall
beobachtet wie gehen sie damit um
ich habe keine idee ich merke nur dass
es an jetzt erst dass es mich
beschäftigt dass es mich ärgert dass es
so ist zumal die gaffer dabei auch noch
oft im weg stehen und die retter
behindern
der respekt vor der arbeit der
feuerwehrleute erscheint immer weniger
zu werden
ja ich hatte also einen interessanten
aber durchaus anstrengenden tag bei der
berufsfeuerwehr koblenz und hier bei
mama vor ort haben wir jetzt unser set
aufgebaut in der landesfeuerwehrschule
rheinland pfalz und wir sprechen hier
mit den betroffenen mit feuerwehrleuten
mit sanitäterinnen und sanitäter mit
polizisten über ihrem harten alltag und
über die anfeindungen denen sie immer
mehr ausgesetzt werden wir sprechen mit
ihnen und wir sprechen mit der politik
denn es muss was dagegen getan werden
[Musik]
die größten anfeindungen erlebt die
polizei und deshalb wollen wir mit laura
kiefer sprechen oberkommissarin hier in
koblenz guten morgen
doch wie weit sie gehen fiel auf streife
fiel auch abends und sie haben uns zum
vorgespräch gesagt es vergeht eigentlich
kein tag an dem sie nicht verbal
angefeindet werden und wir können das
auch in seiner fernsehen ruhig mal sagen
paar mal im monat werden sie mit
[ __ ] mit [ __ ] mit arschloch
beschimpft ja eigentlich machen sie als
polizistin nur ihren job wie
frustrierend ist das für sie also muss
sagen das ist tatsächlich im laufe der
jahre immer ein bisschen abnimmt die
frustration weil es einfach alltäglich
geworden ist und man durchaus immer
damit rechnen muss entweder beschimpft
zu werden und es bleibt mehr oder
weniger allein ab es sei denn man muss
ein bisschen differenzieren dass es ja
man als polizeibeamtin in dem moment
bestimmt und nicht als person also als
privatperson
sie haben uns eine krasse geschichte
erzählt dass sie mal in einer wohnung
einen menschen behandelt haben im
notfall und dann kam der busfahrer von
unten und hat sich bei ihnen beschwert
weil sie mit dem rettungswagen den weg
versperrt haben ja das was macht das mit
ihnen in so einer situation ja das war
schon eine belastende situation insofern
als dass der patient den mann nach hause
gebracht haben
ein sterben der patient war die familie
hat entschieden es soll nicht nur speeds
beziehungsweise auf einer
palliativstation versterben es so zu
hause versterben emotional auch für uns
also kein alltag und die familie war
versammelt kommt der busfahrer und macht
stress ganz genau gestand auf der straße
blockieren natürlich die straße er sieht
sein fahrplan den natürlich auch gerne
einhalten will
aber dann houben hub terror auf der
straße und die angehörigen heulend
rennen raus sagen jetzt haben sie doch
bitte etwas geduld
und ja er hat wie gesagt muss dein
fahrplan im sinn gehabt ich mache mir
dann schon manchmal als ehefrau und
mutter sorgen kommt mein mann seine
kollegen alle gesund wieder nach hause
also mit villen beschossen werden im
einsatz da muss man auch erstmal mit
klarkommen
[Musik]
was brauchen sie denn von der politik
was fordern sie denn von unseren
politikern was können die ändern damit
sie besser ihren job machen können
tatsächlich hilfe konkrete hilfe
dahingehend dass natürlich gibt es tolle
kampagnen aber aus meiner sicht sprechen
die die leute an die uns eh schon
unterstützen das ist ganz ganz wichtig
das brauchen wir auch zusätzlich aber
darüber hinaus brauchen wir auch eine
ausbildung
sie haben eben gesagt konfliktlösungen
suchen oder ähnlichem
also ich bin über 30 jahre in der
feuerwehr davon über 20 jahre
hauptberuflich ich habe noch kein
konflikttraining gehabt aber wir
brauchen hilfe im umgang mit solchen
situationen und das kann nicht sein wie
jetzt angeboten wird teilweise 1
selbstverteidigungstraining zu machen
ich will mich nicht verteidigen ich bin
zum helfen da und nicht zum verteidigen
[Musik]
ich glaube dass wir die maßnahmen zum
beispiel dass er schon ein sonderfall
aber dass wir in bestimmte stadtteile
sagen wenn dort unsere helferinnen und
helfer unsere feuerwehrkräfte gefährdet
sind dass wir dann nur gemeinsam mit der
polizei dorthin gehen das muss dann die
priorität haben dass die kolleginnen und
kollegen sicher wieder nach hause kommen
aber ich denke wir müssen immer wieder
an jeder stelle für die
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz auch wir
haben wir müssen immer dafür werben dass
diese menschen uns retten uns helfen uns
unterstützen in verschiedensten
lebenssituationen und diesen appell an
die bevölkerung an die menschen der muss
eigentlich im grunde genommen tagtäglich
vom oberbürgermeister von dem stadtrat
aber auch von der gesellschaft insgesamt
immer wieder kommen wer diese menschen
angreift greift im grunde die ganze
gesellschaft an
und deshalb gilt für uns null toleranz
diesen angriffen gegenüber und wir
stärken unsere rettungskräfte wirklich
und das heißt ein respekt kampagne das
ist das eine das finde ich auch wichtig
öffentlich klar zu machen wir stehen zu
unseren rettungskräften zur polizei zur
feuerwehr und wir haben viele viele
gespräche geführt
alle mitglieder des kabinetts um auch
ein bisschen mehr zu erfahren das zweite
ist aber natürlich wir haben unsere
gesetze verändert haben eben gerade
gehört des landes rettungsgesetz aber
auf katastrophenschutzgesetz ist
verändert worden der straff rahmen ist
fahrpreis vergrößert worden
auch die eingriffsbefugnisse hinter
größer geworden und zum dritten finde
ich wichtig
wir müssen unsere rettungskräfte gut
ausstatten das ist ein ganz großer punkt
war uns dass wir sagen wir helfen das
wirklich die schutzausstattung wirklich
auch stimmt und natürlich wir müssen die
menschen immer wieder stärken
das war unser mann vor ort in einer
tollen kulisse auch dafür danken wir der
berufsfeuerwehr koblenz und hier der
landesfeuerwehrschule in rheinland pfalz
ist glaub ich klar da ist das ein
wichtiges thema ist aber unser umso mehr
in zeiten von krone wo wir die helfer
tröster retter und kümmerer die in guten
zeiten vielleicht auch manchmal
unsichtbar sind aber umso mehr brauchen
deshalb glaube ich wollten wir hier mit
denen ins gespräch kommen und vielleicht
kann diese sendung ja dazu beitragen
dass der alltag der sanitäterin
sanitäter der polizisten und der
feuerwehrleute in deutschland da ein
bisschen stressfreier und bisschen
besser ist vielen dank hiernach koblenz
[Musik]